new enemies old allies and a deadly
Family Feud challenges don't look to be
any easier for John Wick in the fourth
chapter of his revenge story a little
over halfway through the First full
trailer for John Wick chapter 4 John
Wick approaches an outdoor table in
Paris behind which the Eiffel Tower
looms large there he sits across from
the Marquis De gray Mall in order to
discuss the terms of agreements that
appears will grant Wicked freedom from
the high table's Pursuit there's only
one condition he has to defeat the
Marquis in single combat briefly visible
during this short sequence of the
presences of Winston behind Wick and
Donnie Yen's cane on the Marquis side of
the table this configuration offers a
look at what seems to be the two
principal factions in John Wick chapter
4 with Winston notably back in Wick
despite what appeared to be an outright
betrayal of his old friend at the end of
chapter 3 Parabellum John Wick has also
seen battling Kane at the trailer's
conclusion suggesting their fight might
come near the film's climax giving
Kane's Presence at the Marquis side
earlier on in the trailer it's likely
this battle against Kane is directly
relevant to the overarching conflict
with the Marquis with Wix freedom on the
line the final scenes of John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum saw the
protagonist's long-term Ally Winston
shoot him over a balcony the Continental
owner wanted to keep his power and he
couldn't side with a Rogue assassin who
was being hunted down by all of the high
tables minions so he struck a deal with
the adjudicator that unfortunately led
to Jon having to take a tumble the
trailer for John Wick chapter 4 seems to
show John and Winston having a civilized
conversation suggesting that the former
has forgiven his old allies
transgressions at the same time it's
possible that Winston never intended to
kill everyone's favorite dog-loving
assassin in the first place after all
Winston was hardly surprised when the
adjudicator informed him that Jon had
survived the aforementioned attack was
it part of a plan that only he and John
were in on one particularly interesting
aspect of the John wake chapter 4
trailer comes at the one minute and
three second Mark when the ever Suave
Winston and the ever smug Bowery King
appeared to be exiting a subway train
the two characters have both offered
assistance to Jon but they're not
exactly known to hang out together the
implication seems to be that they're
together and that there might even be
some sort of alliance between the two
however the short Glimpse only shows the
Bowery King exiting leaving the actual
nature of the situation deliciously
unclear are the two on their way to have
a stealthy meeting perhaps summoned by
John could Winston be tailing the Bowery
King for some reason or both characters
secretly super into crocheting and this
sort of stealthy transportation is the
only way they can meet and make colorful
Hacky Sacks without losing base in the
hardcore World they live in it's
probably not that last one but until
further trailers of the movie sheds
light on their travels purpose there's
always hope
the high table and the John Wick
franchise is the mysterious organization
that essentially runs the secretive
world of Assassins and organized crime
although each movie reveals another
aspect of this Hidden World a high table
is an incredibly powerful organization
and their word is essentially law John
Wick chapter 3 Parabellum features WIC
attempting to clear his name after
executing a member of the high table on
neutral ground which is a grievous
mistake in the eyes of this organization
for his actions wake is considered
incommunicado and a large Bounty is
placed on his head after a bombastic
finale in Parabellum Wick escapes from
the clutches of the high table and it
seems as if he will still have to deal
with them in John Wick chapter 4.
however the trailer reveals that his
family sits at the high table I don't
sit at the table your family does this
could mean that he is a sibling or
parent that wields his powerful
Authority or it could be a reference to
the belarusians from Parabellum this may
be the reason why John has been able to
survive such insurmountable odds time
and time again either way it seems like
yet another Dynamic has been interjected
into the John Wick Mythos and it will be
interesting to see if this new Wick
family individual or group on the high
table is a friend or Foe while the John
Wayne chapter 4 trailer is filled with
moments of chaos Intrigue and nail
biting Thrills it does feature a cute
nod to one of Keanu Reeves's most iconic
performances to break the tension a
minute into the trailer a freshly suited
up Wick says I'm going to need a gun
Reeves and Fishburn were first seen
together in 1999's The Matrix in the
film Reeves's character asks for guns
lots of guns the quick line of dialogue
from Reeves's Neo has gone on to become
synonymous with the Matrix a film that
in part is responsible for the John Wick
franchise the late 90s sci-fi for Lake
saw chance the helski taking on the role
of Reeves's stunt double stahelski would
later go on to become the martial arts
stunt coordinator for the two
back-to-back Matrix sequels after a
decade plus of stunt works the helski
decided his next challenge would be
directing roping in Reeves to headline
the titular role in 2014's John Wick the
second flick in the franchise saw
Morpheus actor Fishburn join the
nefarious world of contract killings now
all audiences need is an appearance from
carrion Moss to The Matrix Trinity the
line from The Matrix was previously
referenced verbatim in John Wick chapter
3 Parabellum guns
guns lots of guns only time will tell
just how many times Wick's fourth outing
will reference the Wachowski sisters
game-changing sci-fi franchise
[Music]